in an 11 season career in which he won
the Superbowl not once but twice he's
the reigning Walter Payton man in the
Year award I very rarely say this about
a guest I can just not one thing I just
know about Chris long he smells good
because he's joining us part of the
Gillette deodorant campaign every hero
sweats some never show it Chris long
back here on the Rich Eisen show how are
you Chris I'm doing great man come on
you bet and your perspiration is all
settled everything's good on that it's
under control okay under control thanks
to Gillette deodorant okay we'll get to
that in a second how's retirement
treating you retirements treating me
great God for something that so many
people make sound so scary it's almost
like an oval Hodge tale I think this is
a this stuff's pretty cool I can get
used to this like quote unquote regular
life well in terms of that Chris I mean
just I've been around the NFL block
quite a bit not not like somebody is a
member of the long family Mike but it is
sometimes tough for guys to leave the
field are you missing any part of it at
all
right now I will miss game day I will
miss the opportunity to compete you know
I was at I miss Philly for sure I mean
like I love playing Philly so much that
chapter of my career kind of you know
the New England validated it because
even though I had a lot of individual
success on bad teams I was on bad things
my whole career so winning a Super Bowl
there was great but Philly just kind of
put the the cherry on top for me and it
gave me kind of a stable NFL home to the
Rams have gone to LA I can't go watch
named Louis Rams
Philly's close to home it was so special
what we did will always be the first
team to win a Super Bowl title there so
you know walking away from the game
rather than getting you know released or
listen I mean the reason I walked away
I'm not going to act like it wasn't
because my role was shrinking I made my
role was shrinking and some people were
kind of you know not so high on bringing
me back in the same capacity but I
didn't want to go play anywhere else at
least when I retired so I wanted to
retire an eagle I wanted to have control
over my situation when I think how you
walk away can kind of affect how it's
sitting with you and I feel pretty good
you know like I played well last year
and I'm not getting run out of there I'm
not you know limping around I'm happy so
and I get to be with my family more and
I don't have to go to meetings anymore
or go to practice or any of that stuff
that uh vast majority of the majority of
us hate and don't admit we hate well in
terms of you know family life so what do
you what are you gonna do you're gonna
take kids to school are they old enough
you have what are you gonna lay on this
three and Luke is nine months old so you
know it's pretty busy time I am also
working on some stuff on your your side
of the microphone trying to be like you
I'm actually starting a digital media
company that will be hopefully launching
in February and full capacity and doing
a lot of stuff this fall that'll be
coming out soon no I'm staying busy man
I'm staying busy and I still work out
you know people were joking on me that
look skinny this morning Long Island
good morning football uh-huh but I'm not
that skinny I'm deceptive kind of like
I'm deceptively fast yeah all right so
you know someone in my position doing my
job I just turned 50 Chris you know I
sometimes look around listening for
footsteps are those footsteps yours
coming from my job is that what I know I
know shot at your job I I would like to
you know be down doing a totally
different type of thing I mean I watch
your show and you do a terrific job I'm
at my pods gonna be probably a little
less structured a little more irreverent
and maybe not as much sports but we'll
see as far as the other stuff I'm
looking forward to bringing players into
the fold under our brand to kind of let
them have that that that voice where
they're kind of cutting out the
middleman and they can just kind of
produce things they want to produce or
you know architect their own pod or
their show and and it's gonna be excited
man it's just succeed know that so
that's what I'm used to with football is
having that challenge every day and this
is kind of scarier in a 101 so Chris
Long two-time Super Bowl champion recent
NFL retiree here on the rich
shows your platform I'm gonna be called
we're not sticking to sports what do you
say no I can't tell you the name yet
because it's just such a brilliant name
it's just it just it's it's it's a
perfect digital network name I don't
want to give anybody any ideas okay we
won't stick to sports you know if
anybody knows me I kind of answer
whatever for the most part you throw I
mean I like talking about a whole bunch
of different stuff so we'll have a lot
of fun stuff that's not necessarily
football centric very sport centric but
we'll be showing kind of the other side
of athletes which everybody's doing
right now right but uh but I think
there's some some ways we can do it
that'll separate us a little bit all
right so since so you thinking of
joining the paparazzi as they as we like
to say I'll give you I'll give you one
that everyone's talking about right now
what do you think of Antoniou Browns
saying he's not gonna play doesn't want
to play without the helmet that he wants
Chris what do you think this is an
interesting experiment maybe because
I've never seen something that everybody
ran out it takes on and like I'm
watching people try to assign a
motivation or a reasoning I think
sometimes we have to get good at just
saying I don't know and I know it's not
acceptable in the media because we're
gonna run this story until he puts his
helmet on and takes the field or puts
you know it's a helmet that actually
will protect his brain on and take the
field but I think a couple things first
off great players get leeway this is a
lot of leeway and obviously you're my
excuse he seems a little bit set up but
as a teammate if I were in the locker
much as long as you're a Antonio Brown
week one and you're that first eyelet
hall-of-famer
who by the way the success of the
Raiders in their car you know Mayock and
Gruden's start it all hinges on him so
you really want him healthy in there for
week one and you want him being himself
but you know great artist great football
players great musicians they got to be a
little weird right and this is one of
the eccentricities and they said that
when he was in Pittsburgh I heard he
used to go home with his Simon actually
heard you say that that's true it's why
are you Chris yeah and and and so you
got to be a little different to be great
I think so
and there's more often guys who are
quirky or great and not so weak one just
be out there and be Antonio Brown and
there's nobody will remember this well
my issue again as I said yesterday - in
case you didn't hear that is that what
if he goes through the first three weeks
250 yards receiving just a mere 18
catches 1 1 grab and part of that might
be just because look he hasn't had the
timing down with Derek Carr and you know
you know offenses are in the first
couple weeks of a season or just
everybody because preseason is nothing
any more now so he might sit there and
say this is the whole helmet he can't
get at he can't get his head if you will
out of his helmet or a helmet onto the
head and in and that's an issue that's
my concern and if he does not play at
his level the first few weeks of the
season he's going to be rightfully kind
of sports for that so that's so in play
in this game and I don't think it's a
game to him by the way I'm not sure what
it is and I'm comfortable saying I have
no idea but I think that there's reason
to believe he really might believe that
this is paramount to his success but
what he's doing is he is tightening the
stakes for the first couple weeks of the
season you know if there's a hiccup if
there's some drops there it's kind of
like the Beckham thing where you know he
goes on the boat and people are freaking
out he drops a couple passes in Green
Bay you know I think it's totally fine
I'm not comparing the two like strictly
because they're two totally different
situations but they're there situations
where you do draw some attention and if
you're not at your best people are going
to be on you and that's just the full
side of this coin so if you're great you
get the leeway I think you should get us
get a situation straight and I mean even
if you just held out because you didn't
want to practice as a teammate he's that
great he's transcendent he's
generational he's the key to our success
ideally would you like her to be out
there and be a model citizen yeah but if
you can help us win football games we
won't remember it now if he's not great
the media is gonna be all over about it
alright Chris long sit you're on a
you roll here then I'll throw this other
one at you here Baker Mayfield in GQ
came out today talking about Daniel
Jones I mean another team's quarterback
and a kid who's never probably crossed
paths with Baker and has no beef with
him saying I cannot believe the Giants
took Daniel jones blows my mind some
people over think that's where they go
wrong they forget you've got a win and I
understand he's got a chip on his
shoulder because he was told he can't
and when he was number one overall
everyone thought the Browns were crazy
because of his height I wonder what you
think about that statement from Baker
Chris long well it's that's that's
definitely in first off let me say this
I'm a big fan of Baker and you know any
to that otherwise you're a big fan of
somebody then you're gonna say something
that's slightly critical he's a guy when
I met him I met Baker and I was like hey
never stop talking bro like do you you
know so I'm a big fan of his game and
I'm a big fan of him speaking his mind
but I think that with that comes the
flip side of the coin which is they're
going to see the Giants at some point
Daniel Jones is going to be very
motivated and I know some people have
seen Daniel play this preseason and he's
actually looked kind of promise and oh
the the popular take was like they're
the biggest boneheads in the history of
the NFL but we also don't know what
people are going to be now the only the
only argument you make against the
Giants during has maybe he would have
fallen to them so it really didn't
matter either way but I think it's
irregular for bigger to make those
comments I haven't read the article I
certainly wouldn't make him but Baker's
got to do Baker and Baker's also got a
answer the bell and he's put himself in
a position I don't know if he's the type
of guy that you know he wants to talk a
little trash he wants to say brash
things to elevate his own game and
commitment because you know a lot of
people will just talk I used to talk
trash and some of my biggest games to
ensure that I went out there and I was
my best because I had you know I didn't
want to embarrass myself talk and then
not back it up
so I don't know if he's got a cut kind
of that persona going on but I'm a fan
of Baker I probably wouldn't have said
those things but only Baker can tell you
how he's going to handle it when he
plays Daniel Jones
Chris I gotta tell you what these nuance
takes were on occasion you can admit
that you don't know or you're conflicted
because you like somebody you know
you've got a place on this show
other than that though I'd stick to
sports you know I don't know how you'd
be able to good add I mean that I not
too shabby
I'll be honest with you and then what's
one last football thing here are when so
many people are just talking now the
Eagles can win it all cuz Wentz is back
and you have seen this young man at work
you've seen him grow you've also seen
him overcome injuries or have seasons
cut short by them well what makes him so
good Chris well I mean so first off we
all know that to me I don't know about
anybody in Texas but I think that came
to be in the NFC East or the Eagles and
I think it's it hinges on Carson you
know just as in Dallas their chances
hinge on Zeke I mean Carson's the number
one most important person in that
building and you know they've added so
many options offensively from the tight
ends with Earths and even got her to you
know aguilar Jeffrey to Sean you know
Carson's ability to manage all those
great personalities they're all good
guys but people want the ball right so
his ability to kind of manage those
touches to be the you know field general
there and also their ability to commit
to the run game because a lot of times
you look at that roster tantalizing
you're like we're just going to air raid
people and just throw the ball 40 times
a game that tendency can be dangerous so
commitment to the run game and then
Carson's ability to manage all that and
also just not press and be himself right
because he's got so many great abilities
and he is an MVP caliber player we saw
him 17 there's no need to compete with
Nick or try to be anybody else
Carson is a man he's loved in that
locker room I know there was an article
about him with some anonymous sources at
the end of the year I thought that was
total BS and anybody who knows Carson
knows he's a first-class human being and
he's a leader on
is going to help a lot so McCown in in
that in that quarterback room is gonna
alleviate some of the pressures on
Carson to apply his leadership in that
locker room all right I lied about the
football question what is what are you
willing to share what Kyle's telling you
about the Bears a lot of people on that
bandwagon - well Kyle doesn't tell me
anything about the Bears other than he's
like I feel pretty good I feel like
myself in a couple years from home and I
can do that with the injuries and I can
write you off and how's an immensely
talented guy who's worked hard to get
back to where he is physically and I
think that if the Bears can find a way
to develop mr. Pinsky and and keep him
moving up they're gonna be right back
where they were I know that they're
worried about the departure of the
coordinator because I felt good they
were last year but they also with same
deal weren't great at time so you know
you got to take credit for the mediocre
and with the great so I think that
Pagano is a guy that can come in there
and hopefully not disrupt the flow of
that defense too much and help them pick
up right where they left off man the
defense is scary their offensive line is
solid and offensively it just kind of
hinges on shore Biscay I mean I know
you'd like to complicate it but he's got
to play well and he can't be a can't be
a bottom half quarterback and and and
then have a chance to win the Super Bowl
he's got a really kind of catapult his
progression into that you know upper
echelon a quarterback I think he has the
ability to do that and I really like
their coach so tell me about this
Gillette deodorant
every hero sweats some never show at
campaign Chris what's the scoop here
well I love working with you Gillette
deodorant is a you know it's it's it's
an easy partnership for me because it
aligns with what I believe in and that's
they're kind of talking about what the
quote-unquote modern man what being a
modern man entails and that could be a
lot of things but for me as a as an NFL
player and somebody who have kids look
up to and whatnot it's letting people
know that it's not just football we are
vulnerable we have a lot of different
interests you know for me it's my family
obviously first and my foundation off
the field that I'm very passionate about
so then being able to kind of shed light
on the side
that you know you might have a role
model for young men that are looking up
to football players not anybody else in
any other industry but there's more than
one me GI and it's usually somebody
who's who's really invested in other
areas and it was cool we try to be out
at the Boys and Girls Club in
Charlottesville where we do a lot of
work and then also UVA where I got my
start actually rich the last day before
they tore down you all right Ralph
Simpson's house I was out there on the
field and we shot with that in the
background so it's pretty cool I don't
think it got in the ad um but it's long
gone now
but you got the video no doubt about it
and water boys orgs still going quite
strong that was part of the foundation
as to why you were named and you are the
reigning Walter Payton Man of the Year
Award winner out what's the scoop the
latest on that Chris well yeah that's
thanks for asking that's not worse what
stuff I'm really excited about because I
was super concerned that if I retired I
had a lot left on the table not not only
football-wise but like we had a lot left
on the table with this foundational
stone and and for me the biggest get was
finding an active captain for our water
boards to him because when you're old
and washed up she can't really get on
the phone and be like you can call young
players and try to recruit them cuz
they're like great through the hell are
you
miles Garrett stepped up and he's kind
of taking the torch has the active
captain I'll continue to run on Cochran
Chile my Kilimanjaro hike with a retired
players engagement with retired players
and miles will take the the baton here
for the next hopefully coming 15 years
because I think he's that good I think
he's gonna play a long time and he's
gonna have an opportunity to get fitter
for a gold jacket the guy is is
immensely talented if he continues
develop he's going to be a household
moon for a long time he's a great very
Cape that's awesome man look you always
have a platform with anything that I do
Chris long anytime anytime you want I'm
more than happy to be part of the
Waterboys org
team in any way anything you do that I
appreciate you know I think before
before I go I want to say you're a jet
fan I grew up a Jets fan yes Chris line
I think they got a chance to be really
good I want to shout out Joe Douglas
okay yeah I want to shout out Joe
Douglas I think I think if they can get
to the get through that first half of
the schedule
a chance to be a surprise team winning
nine or ten games and maybe sneaking in
mana you know but they got to get
through that that's the first eight
games as you've probably seen on this
sure look at you I mean you are really
good at this analyzing thing thinking
the guy in my profession that's you're
in the largest footsteps from Chris long
is named happy made for TV like so yeah
that's my last one for you Chris before
I send you and I call these things that
are open to you the world's open to you
what about Broken Arrow - what about
Broken Arrow I thought were timeless
masterpieces and appreciated in a
cinematic arena come on and so like and
also I've been motivated cause I've seen
my dad get C's royalty checks all the
time my firestorm and stuff and so I
need that money now you know I need that
I need those royalty checks to come in
I'd love to do it Broken Arrow reboot
that be great yeah I'm telling you man
while your dad sleeps those checks from
firestorm because someone from Croatia
watched it on DVD comes my only request
is I don't get kicked off of a moving
train by a Christian Slater like my dad
did he went out like a total Punk he got
kicked out of the Train and down into a
gully I thought that was totally beneath
them but you got to do it you go Chris
you do have to do what you have to do at
Joel 9:1 on twitter at la flama Blanca
95 on Instagram you're I'm gonna keep
calling you Chris and come back on and
and and Gillette deodorant again new
tick campaign every hero sweats some
never show a check it all out
certainly on Chris's social media feed
you take care yourself brother right
back at you that's Chris Long here in
the Rich Eisen show for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app